[Music]  whenever we ask any people about the  plastic pollution everyone thinks it's a  plastic straw or a plastic bottle but  nobody knows that the most common  pollutant form of plastic is cigarette  butt  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  i think common people don't know  even i came to know  yesterday only that it has microplastic  and that is polluting the environment so  some awareness should be there  through schools  or through some other organization to  dispose it  of property  [Music]  humans later this everywhere the animals  has no role in this and still they are  facing the most common issues  [Music]  we want the cigarette companies to come  up with some solutions as these birds  can be collected and also they want them  to be responsible that they can collect  these parts and to recycle them  [Music]